it's so wonderful to see both of you uh
congratulations on the film it is such a
powerful and important film to be
released especially at a time like this
uh I want to take you guys back to can
seven minute elevation your first time
being at Ken did you take in that moment
to be there all together to celebrate
we really did yeah yeah as much as you
can you know it's it but yeah
I I uh I feel very lucky I've just
I got invited into a very high level of
this business from a very young age so
um when I the truth is that when I was
very very young I had experienced all of
these things but I didn't I was so young
I didn't appreciate the joy of
experiencing something for the first
time how special that is and so a lot of
times I would feel very stressed out and
looking back on it what I remember is
just the anxiety that I felt rather than
the joy and so going to can knowing that
it was going to be the only time I was
ever going to get to go to can for the
first time in my life I just focused on
the joy and I just took the whole thing
in every second and it was Jeremy's
first time too and we just kept like
reaching over and holding hands and it
felt really significant to to be in a
film that had been chosen to go there
yeah it was great and it was also
to feel the movie land
like an ocean on that audience and to to
feel everyone you know Anne's described
it as like a you know it is like a
roller coaster and there are moments
where the audience collectively lurches
and there are moments where we're all
implicated uh as a society by the story
that James is telling about sort of the
blindness of privilege and complicity
and are sometimes failures to act with
integrity and the difficulty of existing
in a you know a Parenthood trying to be
a good parent and
um the different forms that love can
take you know all of these things the
movie the movie explores all of these
things in a really honest and authentic
way
you know and I think this film is going
to cause an honest conversation with the
anti-semitic tweets that are out there
right now and this is about a Jewish
Family and uh James talked about that we
have a a fight on our hands how
important is it taking responsibility of
what you put out there on on social
media or what you say
I think it's very if you're someone who
has made your life about contributing to
our Collective culture
um it's very important to take it
seriously it doesn't mean everything has
to be heavy it doesn't mean everything
has to be serious but it means that
everything does deserve thought your
highest level of Integrity imagine how
something's going to play out and at the
very least
um
not at the very very least it shouldn't
harm anyone and yeah I'm sorry I'm just
I'm just upset about what happened
me too and and I think that's why the
timing of this film is so important
because it is causing a conversation for
a lot of people
well and I think that you know it just
underscores the idea that people who try
to brush it off or try to say it's not
happening or talking about it's the
thing that makes it exist and if you
don't talk about it it doesn't exist
which is a cognitive dissonance that
really must be so uncomfortable to be in
that kind of a pretzel but um but
actually we do need to talk about this
it very much is here and what we're
talking about are not Concepts we're
talking about people's lives we're
talking about people's experiences we're
talking about children's lives we're
talking about the culture that our
children are growing up in and I think
that children are our most sacred
members of society and we have to talk
about these things because if we don't
talk about them how are we going to get
through them how what hope do we have
I love you too thank you so much really
the honest conversation in four minutes
really appreciate it thank you thank you